all right y'all let's do it
all right y'all welcome back to
yo absolutely
favorite part
[Music]
[Music]
all right what's up y'all welcome back
to riffing with griffin a little late
today but it is what it is that's how we
do it on these parts
um
talking about a lot of stuff today
tinder swindler
inventing anna
nba
transgender swimmer
um and peacemaker
excuse me and whatever else comes up we
are here doing it i want to thank
everybody for being here as usual please
subscribe share and all that and welcome
back
[Music]
yes riffin with griffin
we back again y'all but before we start
with riffing with griffin
let me talk to you about
every plate
where is it every plate
shout out to every plate experience full
plates and fuller wallets with america's
best value meal kit try every plate for
just 179 per meal go to
everyplate.com and enter code griffin179
all right what's up y'all
how you doing
welcome back to roofing with griffin
we out here doing it
we out here making stuff happen
i see you in the chat uh thank you we're
doing it live
we live in full effect so you know it is
what it is uh a lot to talk about today
excuse me uh what can i finish up with
uh start with well you know this past
weekend
i actually went and did
uh crystalia was at the brea improv and
he was doing his crystalline friends he
asked me to go do it i did it it was it
was like crazy
you know he sold out practically he
added a sunday show you know what i mean
it was sold out friday sold out saturday
sold out sunday i even think the last
show almost was a sellout but it was
like but two shows on a sunday it was
crazy so his fans came out and it was uh
i had a really good time with everybody
out there and you know i don't know
feel what you want to feel say what you
want to say i get it you know it's like
i don't know what you want people to do
you know what i mean the guy's my friend
i support him he's going through a lot
he's in therapy you know he made some
mistakes
uh you know
i don't think it was the things that
people are saying about him but he made
some mistakes
and he's working on it i mean the guy's
getting married he has a two-year-old
son like i say he's changed his life and
you know
i thought that that's what this country
was all about you know i think some
people want people
just to go away forever they don't
there's no redemption there's nothing
they just want people like
i you know i believe this and so that's
true and i want you out of my out of the
world you know but you know it just
doesn't work like that when it's someone
that you actually know you know what i
mean
i mean i don't know what you want people
to do i don't know what you want me to
do you know there's always a call on the
internet there's always like people like
how can you support that guy that did
such and such and it's like there's
actually no evidence of any of that
stuff
you know what i mean it's like if he was
you know
it'd be different if like my friend was
like you know being investigated there
was like some sort of like trial or you
know what i'm trying to say if there was
some you know there's none of that stuff
you know uh a lawsuit that was thrown
out uh you know people can think
whatever they want to think but as a as
if it's someone you know if it's your
friend if it's someone you've known for
17 years do you just turn your back i
don't think that that's true you know if
if it were to turn out that like
everything is true that would be a
completely different story i think
everyone would have a completely
different tune that'd be something i'd
have to be like oh man this sucks
because my friend you know but even
still that's my friend and then you know
for your optics or whatever you you know
for the woke people out here that you
have to like whatever you have to go on
the internet and say
which i don't think you really have to
do but you know it happens but i just
want to say you know i i i think the
guy's
doing great i think he's trying to like
i said he's trying to change his life he
made mistakes he'd be the first one to
admit it you know what i mean
you know what i'm saying he was he was
womanizing cheating on this girl he was
you know he he just was living the
lifestyle uh you know and that stuff is
bad um you know we've all made mistakes
like that i just don't think you should
lose your life your career your
livelihood
over that because if we're going to
start doing that i just want to remind
everyone
being an [ __ ] is not exclusive to men
we all men women
non-binary we all make those kinds of
mistakes where we don't treat people the
way we should
if we're gonna start moving people
removing people from society for that
that's gonna be a slippery slope
you know now if you're someone out there
that you know the alleged victims if
they're you're close to those people and
that's what you
you believe that i totally understand
your venom i get it because it'd be like
the same if like if it was someone i
knew and i and i'm trying to support
them but
as a friend of the guy i don't know what
else you want me to do other than i just
have to support my friend and and hope
he
you know on his journey it works out you
know what i'm saying
anyway i don't know what else to say i'm
just going to leave it at that had a
great weekend
so that is what it is
all right you know what let us get into
it guys there's so much to talk about uh
on the episode today
um again like i say uh you can find me
on twitch i'm on twitch daily i'm gonna
be twitching
you know and this week i'm going to
ferris college in michigan
and
i'm also going to be in vancouver at
some
special place vancouver you go to my
website eric griffin.com you can if
you're in the van not vancouver i'm so
sorry calgary if you're in calgary i'm
coming to calgary
coming to calgary so make sure you check
that out okay
all right
so
excuse me like i say
let's get to it
so
hope you like my space is the space nice
my uh you know for you people listen oh
and thanks to everybody that listens to
the podcast too all you audio listeners
i i support you too and also actually
all the people on patreon too guys
excuse me damn it every time i get on
here i start call i think i'm allergic
to something in my room i gotta vacuum
the floor or something but
anyways i am doing bonus content on
patreon so make sure you uh check out my
patreon it's just eric griffin on
patreon yeah i only i don't have a lot
of people on there so the people that do
are on there i really appreciate you and
i'm trying to build that up so i can
really like almost as if i'm doing a
second podcast but it's just on patreon
so
uh you know look out for that thanks a
lot guys for you know the the support
um let's see okay so let's get into what
i wanted to get into uh first today and
that is
basketball the nba guys
nba so you know they had the all-star
break and the slam dunk contest was
garbage and you know whatever the game
was like it is what it is you know steph
curry had 50 points he was like 16
threes the guy was balling it is what it
is i mean i don't really care about the
all-star game anymore it's not there's
nothing because these stars aren't like
the stars of old but maybe i'm just old
so you know you guys that love the young
players you might be like this was great
and it seemed to be a very entertaining
thing but i kind of lost interest and i
didn't even watch all-star saturday i
thought it was kind of cool that
townsend won the three-point contest as
a big man but other than that it was
like whatever
but i never got to talk about this james
harden kevin durant trade this is all
the nba talk right now okay
um as you know
in the beginning of the year excuse me
in the beginning of the year i was
talking about last year i was talking
about could this work i didn't think it
was going to work and here it is it
didn't work
it just did not work these guys only
played uh 16 games together total kyrie
irving james harden and kevin durant
three sort of divas if you really think
about it
you know
just starting with kyrie irving
from duke so here's the things about
kyrie irving hello cc moon thank you for
the super chat
so uh
kyrie irving he got hurt at duke his
freshman year never really played at
duke he got drafted into the league from
there he was on a really bad cleveland
team nothing was happening with then
then lebron james comes changes
everything but then they have fallout so
he falls out with lebron james doesn't
want to be there anymore he goes to
boston
he totally messes up the chemistry there
the he he that doesn't work then he has
to go to the nets and while he's at the
nets it ain't working and then there's
the pandemic
so then during the pandemic he also was
like i'm not going in the bubble he
didn't want to go into the bubble so
then he was out there
then
kevin durant comes
to um
the nets they trade for james harden and
you think oh wow
this is going to be the thing right
uh it doesn't work out once again in the
championship kyrie irving gets hurt
you know i think he's lost himself two
championships because of injury
for sure cleveland would have beat
golden state
if kyrie irving didn't get hurt and even
if kevin love didn't get hurt just one
of those guys
they beat golden state and the whole
face of the league would have probably
changed you know what i mean like maybe
golden state doesn't have that um
wherewithal to now go and win the
championship the next year and win 73
games even though they lost you know
what i'm saying so maybe they don't even
because they didn't win the championship
they have no confidence and they don't
go on to this a magical 73 win run
and you know maybe cleveland goes back
to back and we're talking about lebron
james in a completely different way
just because of kyrie irving's injury so
they lost that championship okay they
come back they win he's healthy they win
all right
then
um anyways and so then you have last
year
last year they're beating the [ __ ] out
of milwaukee okay with kyrie irving and
kevin durant playing mostly because
james harden was hurt so he wasn't
really giving you a lot of minutes and
they were beating the brakes off
milwaukee kyrie irving gets hurt you
know the rest milwaukee goes on to win
the championship so it's like damn kyrie
can you stay healthy him and uh what's
his name anthony davis from the lakers
same thing man he's just injury prone
right then but then you have this other
thing with kyrie irving it's the head
case stuff he's you know he's
he says he's got some personal issues
but he's had a party you know what i
mean he's always like oh i can't play
because of this reason or that reason
and now he's like you know he don't want
to get vaccinated and so now new york
has this stupid rule by the way i don't
agree with him and i don't agree with
new york you know what i mean but it is
what it is he is young and healthy i
think if he got covered he would he
would survive it you know does he have
pre-existing conditions and all that
kind of stuff who knows so he's just
saying i don't want to take it okay i
can respect that but that's part of
being a head case you know i mean it's
still part of the baggage and now we're
here you find out him and james harden
don't get along boom now
james harden is gone
then you have james harden who was with
oklahoma city
to me when you look back at those
oklahoma city
in the championship against cleveland
not cleveland against miami
james harden disappeared
he had a really bad game and he he just
disappeared that's when all this him not
showing up in the playoffs started it
was there they don't want to pay him so
he leaves they send him to houston he
becomes a star
but he can't close he can't finish in
the playoffs and that becomes his rep he
can't finish in the playoffs all right
so then that's the thing that's a cloud
over his head then
you know
how dwight howard comes they can't
finish it
chris paul comes he can't he can't play
with him
uh what's his name um
what's the russell westbrook comes
he's a whole other issue but still
clashing with james harden it doesn't
work now james harden is like i don't
want to be in houston anymore and he
sort of bullies his way out
that code of drama
from all reports james harden wanted to
go to the sixers
but they didn't want to do business with
daryl mori so he had so they did this
nets deal i don't think he ever wanted
to be there
hey case then you got kevin durant
kevin durant who
when he was in oklahoma city star
fighting with russell russ brooke that
was a thing they didn't get along
kevin durant doesn't he again him too
him and james harden same kind of thing
in in game in neil's game and i've
talked about this on the podcast before
i've showed the numbers and everything
like he just he didn't have the greatest
finish
in in the championship against lebron
james all right but when he was oklahoma
city you know and then they play golden
state they're up 3-1 they lose and then
he leaves oklahoma city and goes to
the greatest you know the greatest
regular season team and then he goes on
to win two championships
hey case
decides i'm decides i don't want to be
in golden state anymore
goes to the nets
all right so now he's here with the nets
and he's injured
all the time
i'm just telling you guys right now
kevin durant's best days
are probably behind him
we he recovered from a really terrible
injury
but he is always injured
he has not played a full he misses 20 30
games for the last three years in a row
okay he didn't even play during the i'm
saying two years you know what i mean so
he may and now he's hurt again and
they're waiting to see he may never be
the same man him kawhi leonard anthony
davis
these superstar guys but they keep
getting injured i don't know if kevin
durant will ever be the same hopefully
he does so he can really see some really
good competition but i'm starting to
think that that's it for him man that's
it
so
now
now
you so you have those three head cases
right now james harden once again
decides i'm gonna leave i don't know why
kevin durant is mad about it why are you
mad bro
like you know in the all-star selection
thing he kind of had a little bit of an
attitude about james harden right why
remember when you left russell russbrook
when you guys had a great team you were
up 3-1 and lost i was looking for you to
come back and redeem yourself no you
decided to leave
then you went golden state you decided
to leave so like
you should have been like good job james
shake his hand like i totally get it i'm
out
right so now
so you know james harden now he goes to
the sixers then you got ben simmons on
the other side here ben simmons complete
head case again from all reports
his scouting report when he was coming
into the league
and i'm just getting this information
from a few nba websites and then
watching a lot of sports talk stuff
you know that he always was somebody
that didn't work hard
he was always like somebody that you had
to really challenge to get the best out
of him
so here he is now in philly a hard city
to play in
you know you always see they boo in
their own team and [ __ ] like that right
so you got this guy hey case
he ain't getting along
with doc rivers and not getting along
with joel embiid and i'm iffy on doc
rivers too man
doc rivers might be the most overrated
coach in history okay he just he had
kevin garnett paul pierce and ray allen
and they won one championship and they
won that championship because of
freaking
kevin garnett was like i'm not going to
be denied but they went seven game
series the whole way and then they never
got back to the championship so
you know what i mean like i don't wanna
so so you have to deal with that so you
got jack rivers who's not good with
stars trust me i had clipper season
tickets i saw it
he he something happens with stars with
doc rivers is great with like those like
mid-level guys he gets the best out of
them but when it comes to like
superstars they start bickering and so
the same thing happened here right so
now ben simmons is claiming you know
mental health issues and
listen
i'm neither here nor there with this i
don't that's probably a whole other
nuanced discussion
about what you should do about mental
health it's like it's like playing hurt
right you know you you they're all hurt
you play hurt can you play with you know
you know should you even be playing if
you if if your mental health can stop
you like that
should you be in a million dollar
contract then i mean it's just something
to think about and then and then there's
people that don't believe him there's
people that think he's faking the mental
health so he could try to get his money
that's a narrative that's out there but
regardless
he's a head case he a prima donna now
he's with kyrie and kevin
kevin durant i don't see that working
those three guys are just that's like
the most dramatic team it should be the
new york drama queens you know what i
mean
so i i don't know
so that's how i feel about that you know
so we will see and in terms of the trade
itself i feel
like i feel like
can james harden get his act together
can he finally get over the hump
you know and because now he got this
superstar in joel embiid who also gets
hurt a lot let's hope he don't get hurt
can like joe embiid carry him to be like
get the best out of him and then they
can go on because now the east is wide
open so i really like that i love that
it's milwaukee looks good miami looks
good the nets look good but anyways
you know
it's it's it's weird but we'll see so
right now i'm pulling for the sixers
though because i'm
you know i went to a small high school
so i was a big man even though i'm only
six three so i'm partial to the big man
i went i went to big man camp when i was
in high school that's that's how you
know it was funny because when i was at
big man camp everybody was calling me
little man
so that was funny so i always partial to
big man so i would love to see the
sixers do it you know because i think
joel lambeat is really good
uh
you know what i mean
all right let's get to
next on the list baby
next now this is the next discussion
we're going to have
is we're going to be delicate and we're
going to be
you know
we'll have a
simple nuanced discussion about
leah
thomas the transgender swimmer
in the ivy league okay
so
i wanted to talk about this
um
first of all
i feel bad for
the woke people
i really do
you know i thought
i want to laugh at them i want to be
like sort of facetious about
how crazy it is
how unenlightened they can be about
certain things
but this is actually sad to me
because
if you're a feminist
and you can be a man too if whatever you
know male male any man can be a family
if you're a feminist but you're also
woke
your brain is going crazy right now
because you don't know what to do with
this situation
okay
so let's talk about it like this
so i'm gonna talk about like this as
sensitively as i can
so you have a woman we're saying a woman
born in a man's body
has decided to shed as much man stuff as
she can
so she can be presented
as a woman
all right
and now that person
is now competing against natural born
women
and demolishing them at sports
and it's happening in other
fields
the problem with woke people is they
can't have
a nuanced discussion
everything has to be
extreme
so
as i'm talking about this
there's a contingent of woke people who
think i'm transphobic because i'm
talking about this
i'm not
this is nuanced
there's details and context
that is important to bring to the
discussion
but if you're one of these woke people
that like
you don't want to do that because if you
start to do that if you add context
details nuance
if you start adding that you will
realize how close-minded you really are
and they don't want that their brains
are going crazy
and if you're like a female feminist
who's also trying to be supportive
i know this is messing with you it has
to be
because you're sitting there going like
oh the women are getting beat by someone
who used to be a man
and you don't want to be mad about it
but you are
let's be honest you are
and i think that's fine
i think that
it's so fresh and new what is happening
that we don't know
these things these these people are
blazing a trail and we're not and it's
moving so fast
we are not
we're not caught up to it yet
i mean
come on man
i am not being a hater
or being hateful or saying anything
wrong by saying
yo
this was a man with man
muscle
man muscle
body
type
and is now
competing in sports
against
women and we already know
that men are stronger faster
more athletic than women
what are we doing
why can't we just talk about it like
that
i want this person to live a happy
fulfilled life
but it's a privilege to play sports
not a right
it's a privilege
so
you
are now living your truth
maybe you don't get to play sports
anymore
until we figure out how we're gonna do
it
maybe you do it for fun
as a hobby
down at the ymca
or down in like the swimming park league
i don't know what kind of you know but
not on a national
olympic type scale
where records are being broken
that's unfair to me and why can't we
have a discussion about it like that
without people coming at you thinking
oh man you hate transgender people
and then the transgender people have
been so persecuted
they've been hated on for so long that
they have to they're like
cornered rats
so they have to attack all the time
we have to find some compassion
on both sides so we can sit down and
have a discussion about it without it
turning into
something that is not
but it's like
i
know women are not because they got on
jk rowling for talking about this taking
a stance right and then they canceled
her like oh you're transphobic but now
people are starting to go oh
you know what i'm not transphobic
because i find this to be a problem and
i think women if you're being honest
with yourself
you got a problem with this
you got a problem with this you know and
you're not a terrible person because you
have a problem with this
we're not terrible we're just trying to
figure this [ __ ] out we're just trying
to figure it out and i think that if we
have some
nuanced
details
with context and compassion
we can talk about this and figure it out
because maybe it's like all right the
transgender like you know like maybe
it's like in golf
where like you know the woman's t is
like further maybe you have to figure
out some sort of algorithm where we go
all right this is the average time of
men this is the average time of women
and you figure out some point in there
where
you know okay if they're if it's a
transgender athlete they get docked this
amount of seconds so we can somehow
level the playing field so it feels fair
we just wanted to feel fair
without the woke people who are so
unenlightened guys
these woke people and i feel sorry for
them honestly i'm not being facetious
because they're being distracted
this is an issue that we should be
talking about
but they're being distracted by the
people that want to control the
narrative so they hit them with the like
well you hate you're being transphobic
and now the woke people have to be like
oh am i being transphobic without no
thoughts no no conversation like i say
with it's nuanced there's context
there's d the devil is in the details
if you leave all that stuff out you're
just left with feelings
we can't
live
like that
we have to be able to talk about things
that are important
without people making you feel bad about
it or distracting you
for their own purpose
that's what happens with obesity man
obesity like
sometimes
we need to talk about obesity the way we
talk about covet
like because we are way past
the omicron variant of obesity
like this we had a dangerous level of
obesity
but the food industry the people that
make sugar the people that make fast
foods they want us talking about
body positivity
so all the woke people feel like i'm
being mean to fat people to out of shape
people to unhealthy people i'm being
mean when i say hey we should do this
and no then we got people on the
internet
like posting pictures of people's fat
parts
oh look at this girl's fat belly and
we're supposed to be like oh girl you
beautiful girl you're so beautiful and
we're getting distracted
we're getting distracted these two
things should be separated it's nuanced
yes
have confidence in yourself i get that
but at the same time we should also talk
about
health
and safety in a real way
like we need to talk about
taking care of ourselves so we can live
longer
we need to talk about how obesity
heart disease is the number one killer
in the united states
and one of the main causes of heart
disease is obesity
can we can we have a discussion where
we're talking about this and it's not
about how we're making fat people feel
bad
and then you know what i mean like it's
like it's bananas to me but that's how
people are being
distracted they're being distracted with
this woke movement
and like
pfizer and these kind of people they're
doing it too
they're doing it they're they're instead
of talking about like how much money
they're making or or you know whatever
you feel about the vaccine
they're putting out things about like oh
look at our our employees we have
diversity like we're being distracted by
diversity and body positivity and and
transgender
the transgender like you know being told
that you're transphobic like the
transphobic movement
the transphobic culture that they keep
putting on us just because we're trying
to challenge
we're trying to be like hey this don't
feel right
i don't care who you are it don't feel
right
you know what i mean you could just look
like when you just see pictures of this
person you go
you go
that's a dude right like that's your
thought
you know just be honest about it and so
because you could and why do you say
that because you're seeing dude stuff
dude muscles and body structure and and
strong leg you're seeing a certain you
know you know you know what i mean
i don't know
you know what i mean because there is
like because even if you see like a
bodybuilding female you know what i mean
they're still
like the fastest woman in the world
angle is not faster than the fastest man
in the world so even if a woman is like
you know you know how you ever see like
a chick who's like oh man you're like
damn she buff as hell she still can't
compete with a man
on on when you level the playing field
like that so we look at our eyes are
telling us hey just don't feel right but
the people that want to make you feel
like you're transphobic are making you
like you're like oh yeah i guess i have
to be supportive
we can be supportive man
we can be supportive
of this person's life
live your truth
good for you
you you
are now
out in society
presenting yourself the way you always
knew you should be
but that don't mean
you have the right
to compete
in a sport where clearly there's an
advantage
i'm done
we're done with that
okay
all right guys let's now get to
the reviews
all right let's get you there reviews of
stuff first
i want to talk about this cat dude
what's up with this dude have y'all seen
the twinder twin
twindler tinder
swindler
all right
the tinder swindler man i mean this dude
the tinder his name
simon
vive or whatever his name is
man dude
[Laughter]
i don't know how i feel about it if i'm
being honest
can i have an honest nuanced discussion
about this i don't know how i feel
there are
super lonely needy people out there who
are just looking for love and can't find
it and it's a shame when a manipulative
narcissist
con artist
gets in their life
you know
you know per let me make it even
personal to you man i remember when i
was a kid my mom was a single parent
okay so you know when your mom's a
single parent you know she's like in her
you know
mid-30s you know what i'm saying like
when i was young you know and even when
she got into like late 30s and i'm like
you know
what however old i was you know she's
still trying to date she out there she
out here trying to do it you know and so
i remember my mom
was telling me she like started dating
some guy and i hadn't met him yet and
the guy was big about like not meeting
me yet or something but even as a kid i
started to be like
this don't sound right because the guy
was like
a sweet talker and then all of a sudden
talking about and and these swindlers
they always have like a sob story like
their mother's dying of cancer or
there's always something like that so
and this guy was like uh you know he's
supposed to be independently wealthy you
know here's my mom's single mom with
raising a son
you know
working her ass off so we can live the
best like middle class life we can right
and here comes some casanova dude who's
like i'm rich and i'm gonna take care of
you and i'm gonna actually show you how
to invest and and it just got weird
where the guy was trying to get money
and it turned out he was a con artist
and my mom figured it out you know
because she saw like you know people are
sending flowers to this guy's father or
mother it was some story i don't
remember what it was and then she
figured out like oh
two or three other women are trying to
do the same thing and then it just
turned out to be a scam but it's
disappointing because
when people pretend to be rich
they are selling a lifestyle you know
what i mean they selling a lifestyle and
then like someone who's not lived that
lifestyle is kind of like in they're
like oh
i want to be like that and i could tell
my mom was like sick of working she was
like i don't want to keep working i'm
you know she's struggling and you know
what i mean she's like oh here comes
some rich guy that's going to help me
all i got to do is invest in his company
you know what i mean it was like some
[ __ ] and she figured it out we were
done and even i knew too i was like
telling her like that'll sound right mom
uh-uh i don't like this guy and his
whole game too was like i'm gonna make a
perfume
your own perfume and you know what i
mean i saw my mom getting ready she was
like i'm gonna have my own perfume and
blah blah and i was like uh oh that
don't seem right you know what i mean
and so this is that kind of guy
so i'm making it personal i'm not just
clowning these women because
my mom was one of those women or almost
was you know what i mean so these guys
these women but at the same time i i
have a hard time feeling sorry
at what point are you giving a person
you just met all your money
like what do they to do like is the dick
that good like
is he slanging where it's like people
women are like
oh
i take all my money you know i i don't
get it i mean and the dude is like he i
you know what i mean
he looked like a like like him and i
almost looked the same can i be the
tennis winner
what uh y'all i mean i just
i don't know
it's hard for me so i got a pole up
right now
you know what i mean i don't know but
let me see the poll do you feel bad for
the people he swindled and it's like 61
of y'all saying no and i totally agree
the dude's a monster though okay i agree
with you
the dude is a
monster right let's just be real but
damn
how am i supposed to feel so i will say
this moving forward
moving forward
if any woman
continues to get swindled by this dude
i'll give a
blank about you okay
when a dude got a documentary
about him being a swindler
and you still going out with him
he got game son
let's just be let's just
you know what let's just be fair too
player can play man the dude got game
because
he still got he got a new girlfriend
it's like what
so
i don't know
it's very like it's one of those
documentaries that you watch and you
just go damn this is this a lot you know
it's really you really just you don't
know how to feel so i do get into the
review of it i highly recommend watching
it it's a fascinating watch
you know there's a part of you that just
you will sit there and be like oh this
never happened to me and you see you
feel sorry for people and then you root
for them you know because you're like
come on girl get him back and and then
like after all that right
millions of dollars swindled and
he go to jail for four months
i was like
and he already out and then these women
are still like damn
and i wouldn't be surprised if he's
trying to hit them up
and like
and like you know you know what i mean
like i don't know but it is
a very fascinating story
and i do
highly recommend it
all right
next on the list
we got
inventing anna
inventing anna let me get everybody's
name on here because i'm i'm live so i
usually have these websites ready to go
already
uh inventing anna
julia garner is the the star you know
she's in um
she plays the uh the the the old country
ghetto girl
in um
what's it called why am i forgetting the
show's name on netflix oh my god i'm
really i really feel old sometimes dude
what's the name of the show um
the ozarks
okay
so
the ozarks it's um
good show man
and she's really great you know and it's
just it's also like a good thing to like
google
like google what this is really about
because it's really it's loosely based
off a real girl this real woman who
became a socialite in the new york
area and like convinced people
to give her money convinced her that she
was like some german heiress and she had
all this money and it was
it was just a fascinating
you know display of con artistry
you know what i mean and and she's
actually playing
i was talking to somebody the other day
and they don't agree with they don't
like her accent but you know i don't
know what a german accent sounds like
you know the way she's
to me she feels like she's doing a good
job maybe people in germany are like oh
this is terrible but you know i think
she's doing a good job you know she's a
great actress she's already won two
emmys for ozarks and um and everybody
else in the show is doing pretty good
too anna uh chum chum whatever her name
is anna chum
she's doing great
laverne cox transgender actress doing
great
i guess we didn't have to say that but i
just want you to know she's doing great
she was in uh orange's new black doing a
great job and anders from uh workaholics
is also in it and he's doing a really
great job too i had to shout him out
like anders killing it on that show man
so um yeah shout out to
uh
the the makers of
inventing amy
and i'm sorry inventing anna but yeah
cause like apparently it you know
it's it's based off
um
like a real person you know
based off this true story of anna
sorokin
and she like had some fake name and you
know
and she posed as a she fooled new york
high society
you know it's like
you know it's like it's all about like
the the fakeness of that is great like
she faked it she played the part she
looked the part you know and
and then she actually
fooled all these people and it's like a
real chick man and when you see the real
girl you just go how did this girl do
this
because they got somebody like because
even the actress herself she's pretty
but she's no supermodel you know what i
mean
because they make reference to this in
the show a lot where she's like
they say like i don't know how she did
this she's not that great looking like
that's the reference they're trying to
make and like when you see the real girl
you just go damn how did this chick pull
this off but she got it man she it's
like there's something about charisma
and
and that moxie and that it factor like
the girl got the it factor
you know and
you know i think that the actress
playing her really i think she portrays
it very well
so
you know i don't know
um
and and i believe that the girl
i believe she's in jail i don't like
yeah i think she's currently in jail
because she was like it was like you
know bank fraud
like she was doing some crazy stuff like
i don't even know if like what she did
can actually even be done because like
there's a part in the movie where she
like she let's say let's say it's bank
of america so like i go to bank i'm with
bank of america so let's say i go to
bank of america and i deposit
in one branch i go here's i deposit ten
thousand dollars in the branch so they
put it in my account and let's say
because i have a high value account they
say
all right okay the money is instantly
available then she goes to another
branch
but there's no money she wrote writes a
check that has no nothing in the account
so she writes a check for ten thousand
they they post it to the account like
she has ten thousand then she goes to
another bank and withdraws ten thousand
in cash
from her own account
that's the kind of stuff this chick was
doing i mean i was like damn you know so
i think they've
since changed things you know because
people got fooled so much i i just have
no idea but
like i say this was a very um
it was a very
it's a very it's a good show i i do
highly recommend you guys watch it
uh and you know and see and see how and
see how it ends all right
all right um
next up on the list
guys is
wait let me find the is the show
the peacemaker
i finally watched peacemaker
people been telling me to
to to watch peacemaker for a while now
and i was like all right i'll check it
out and i'm telling you right now
peacemaker is fantastic
i mean
this is such a fun
show
and i think what i like most about it uh
what i like most about it is
um that it's it's like rated r you know
what i mean
like i i like adult humor so this show
reminds me
of like how we used to make movies 15
years ago where
you know we weren't like worried about
all these things that we're worried
about you know even though these things
happen in society we're trying to
portray them on the screen
everybody's like oh you you know you
can't treat women like that you can't
treat minorities like that you can't
have violence you can't you know and
this show is just kind of like ah go
[ __ ] yourself we're gonna do this
and i really like it john cena is
like that dude is
funny
okay he's just funny in this show the
show's even funny the intro of the show
is freaking funny they do this they did
this dance thing
that's funny
um
yeah so if you know about a suicide
squad so this is like
playing off the last suicide squad so
they make reference to that movie a lot
and they even show clips from it so this
is like
you know so if you saw the last suicide
squad peacemaker was a part of the
suicide squad and now he's like trying
to whatever the the the events of
suicide squad
have happened and now he's trying to
just be get back to normal and it's his
story okay and it's really funny you
know what i mean it's just funny about
him and his father that that
relationship and then the other people
in in in the show and how they interact
with him and he's just like the most
inappropriate guy man
it would be like if michael scott on the
office had superpowers or if he was like
a big gigantic guy he's kind of like
that he just inappropriate
and
you know what i mean and so
i do recommend watching this
show
and um yeah this is some i don't know
what you're talking about you know in
the chat about john cena and china and
all this that's a whole other discussion
if you don't want to like him for that i
totally get it that's totally your
provocat
prerogative but when i look at something
i try to be like well is that the
character it's kind of like do you
listen to r kelly's music anymore i
don't know that's up to you that's your
choice if you feel like you're
supporting a guy because you listen to
the music and you don't want to do that
because he was convicted and he's in
jail i get that but like you know i
don't know about this whatever john cena
did with china it's like all right
whatever
you know what i mean um
i'm just telling you i think the show's
funny and i think everybody in the show
is doing a great job
and i like how and it's a little woke
right there's some woke elements
but they're handling it well they're
making it seem like this is this is
seamless in a part of the show as
opposed to like where you you really
look at the thing and go why is this
casted this way you know what i mean the
way they do it in this show it's really
well done
and
you know i totally
i like it you know what i mean
so
oh i didn't even give my woo-woos for
everything so we just do them all
together so tinder swindler
um
peacemaker
and
what's the other one
inventing anna i i give all these shows
sick five wobu's
[Music]
[Music]
all right so
all those things get all those woo-woos
so i like i say i highly recommend you
guys watch
all the things we said and you know if
you have something that you want to like
comment about please try to comment with
some compassion she's like like you have
a point you know what i'm saying
like don't attack me personally just
freaking if you have something to say
about especially the swimmer thing the
transgender stuff you want to talk you
want to get into a discussion about it
let's get into a discussion about it but
man keep keep your like
heightened feelings out of it because
that's not going to help that does that
doesn't help the situation
at all all right oh
you know what i forgot to do
and we're gonna do it now
because damn it it's supposed to be a
mid-roll too uh
you know what it is what it is whatever
you know what i mean
it is what it is guys but you get
you have me you had me going but i we
need to talk about every plate okay so
uh every play sponsor of the show
um they sent me and i love it i'm just
telling you right now work smarter not
harder let every play plan shop and
deliver everything you need to cook
delicious meals so they send you a box
and they have everything in there i had
some like oh i had some like uh these
like fancy quesadillas i got to make and
then they and there was like these like
sriracha pork chop uh it was it you feel
fancy you feel like emerald when you're
cooking so
it really is good every you know they
they have all the quality ingredients
you need they come carefully packed and
pre-portioned and that's the best thing
about this type of thing is because when
you go to the store and you want to make
something you don't even know
how
to make it like you don't know you know
what i mean like you don't know like if
you need an onion you don't just buy one
onion you're like let me get six onions
and then you're spending so much money
these kind of pre-portioned things
they're giving you exactly what you need
just for that meal so it's great
um
[Music]
it really is great
it's easy to cook you know it's
pre-portioned and and the price is
absolutely amazing try every plate for
just 179 per meal
by going to everyplate.com and entering
code
griffin.179 not dot griffin one seven
nine so code griffin 179 get started
with every play for just 179 per meal by
going to everyplay.com and entering
codegriffin179
that's code griffin
179
at everyplate.com for just one dollar
and 79 cents per meal that's up to
104 dollar
value
all right y'all i'm supposed to do that
commercial like a long time ago but you
know we're live and in full effect
you know i got nobody here reminding me
oh very funny you know eric be eating
every plate you know what you getting a
timeout
i'm giving you a timeout and i think
that was funny
[Laughter]
so that is what it is right there but
anyways guys
i will be out of town come check my
website eric griffin.com you know what i
mean so you can uh
you know see
where i'm at i'm coming to a town near
you
you know make sure you guys thank you
for being here make sure you subscribe
share
and again remember i'm also gonna be
doing way more content
on the patreon so go to patreon.com eric
griffin and to get more episodes and
like i'm interacting with the fans too
like if you there's a show you want me
to watch you know
it's already happened i already started
watching the show
that somebody recommended so i'm gonna
watch it and then start and review it so
that's how we're gonna do that also
check me out on twitch i'm going to go
on twitch in about 30 minutes i'm
watching some clothes right now because
i'm leaving tomorrow so i gotta pack so
check me out on twitch i'm on twitch
daily so that you know i have a lot of
fun doing that so be a part of that if
you want to subscribe
and make sure when you're um when you go
to the patreon
or you can be a youtube member and
you'll get that content all right so
youtube member or patreon member you
will get that content um for with the
library so guys i hope you enjoyed the
show
once again if you have some comments
you want to like hit me up
you know let's have a you know
a nuanced
compassionate conversation about all the
topics that we brought up but once again
thank you for being here i really
appreciate you guys and i will see you
next week
[Music]
[Music]
representing
[Music]
with that